[Music]
I am a meat good afternoon and I'm here
I'm very excited today we have a special
guest with us just a quick question how
many of you have heard of the Encore or
context-aware awesome today we are going
to talk about the Encore poor
context-aware with an actual customer
who's actually deployed it this is
Samuel Samuel is my in some ways my
dream customer he wants to try
everything we do and in some ways he's
my nightmare customer because he breaks
everything that we do but that's a good
thing so Sam had Samuel had two
conditions he had for talking one is
this is not a marketing presentation so
he's going to tell you what worked and
didn't work and he really does do that
and the second is that he's going to
talk about being on another cloud and I
said I think some people here might
might be on that same cloud so it's okay
just out of curiosity how many people
are running a second cloud another cloud
there's probably more you guys are just
not saying so let me jump ahead because
there are three speakers today they
asked us to introduce ourselves I'll go
first is sam sam as the star of the show
he's a security engineer at Airbnb
next is Gungan works on cloud identity
here talked about G suite and then
lastly is me yes that is really me I am
on the cloud security team working on
identical proxy and other such products
and so we'll talk about all those as we
go forward I would give it to Sam I just
wanted to highlight he hasn't started
the show we're gonna let him do most of
the talking he's gonna set up the
challenges
Goggan and i will quickly come on stage
and talk about how we have tools to
solve all those problems and then samuel
will come back on stage and tell you how
he broke those things to make him work
so I'll leave it to you cool hey
everybody I'm Sam so first I just want
him to notice disclaimer that's at the
bottom of this slide
I've been required to include it because
I am going to talk about other
other clouds about AWS so we've had a
lot of challenges but I just want to go
over briefly what our corporate
architecture looks like it's probably
very similar to a lot of companies so we
have users they have browsers they
talked to a lot of hosted SAS apps slack
G suite github tons of these apps but we
also have a large corporate
infrastructure of what we want ourselves
so this is composed of applications
primarily running on AWS along with some
applications that run in some local
computer all of airbnb.com
runs in AWS but we have some supporting
services that run with some local
compute primarily for some latency
reasons with SIP routing and things like
that but this is really what our
infrastructure looks like scaled down
simplified very basic but we've invested
heavily in an endpoint instrumentation
and reporting we used tools like OS
query from Facebook along with tool that
we developed internally called stream
alert which runs in AWS lambda and
analyzes the results coming from hose
query suite we have a ton of data that
we look at coming from our endpoints and
then our users get to our internal
services through VPN or 802 and X when
they're in an Airbnb office whether
that's on a wired connection or a
wireless connection if you're not on if
you're not in an office then you're
gonna be using VPN so this is basically
what our infrastructure looks like
there's a very strange transition there
so um Airbnb was founded just a few
blocks away from here in Soma about ten
years ago and over the past over the
past decade has grown has grown out of
just San Francisco and we now have
offices all around the world with
thousands of users supporting our
community of millions of hosts and
guests our largest office is still here
in San Francisco but with all of these
offices we ended up building a network
for easy the users to get to our
services but this growth has presented
us with a constant challenge when you're
just one office it's pretty easy to get
into your resources that might be
running in AWS by you know white listing
the IP of your network or something like
that but as we've expanded that's that
hasn't really worked so what we've
realized with that is that the worst
experiences that our users have are
inconsistent ones so well you might be
in San Francisco and be able to get
everything if you go to Portland you
know you haven't gone very far that's
still in large Airbnb office but you
might not be able to access everything
that we have and the problem really just
gets worse the farther away that you get
from San Francisco or it's gotten worse
so
a couple years ago we started a project
called work anywhere and this comes out
of three kind of realizations the first
is that securing user networks is pretty
hard at least doing it in a way that's
user friendly and scalable so for us 802
X and VPN have had a lot of edge cases
where they don't really work so in the
case of 802 and X when we're expanding
into a new city we might start off in a
managed service office or something like
that where we don't control the whole
network so it'll look like an Airbnb
office it'll feel like one but the
network that they're coming through
isn't run by us it's really just an
internet connection so there are
generally ways that we could end up
deploying you know to an X there through
like remote access points or something
like that but generally like getting
those offices which are errbody offices
on the network is not so easy so we end
up having those users who use VPN on and
then VPN has so many edge cases to where
VPN falls over from users that are
really far away from their VPN gateways
or for users who are flying in an
airplane and they can't approve MFA or
it's really hard for them to get MFA
working when they're on VPN there's just
so many edge cases where just like
securing the network is hard then what
we've realized that is latency makes
things even worse we haven't been able
to defy physics quite yet so when we
have these offices all over the world
and most of our applications are running
in u.s. East in AWS as sim you know
companies end up running things in like
a single region or a single country the
latency to these apps can just be really
bad
and you know we can't get you any closer
to that application but it's really easy
to make things works so we've known
about this issue for a long time
particularly for users who are like in
Australia and if you are in Australia
and say you're in Sydney and you want to
connect to the VPN you're probably going
to connect to the VPN end point that we
have running in Singapore because the
one that's closest to you but if you're
in Sydney and you're connected to a VPN
gateway in Singapore that traffic is
going to route actually way out of the
way to go to Singapore and then come all
the way back to the east coast of the US
it's over 50% farther to go from Sydney
to Singapore all the way to the US than
it is just to go from Sydney to the US
it might not be evident if you if you'd
like without a globe but that's that's
the reality and so latency becomes a
problem for even more users it becomes
really obvious for me when I'm on an
airplane with the explosion of use of
satellite based Wi-Fi on and on planes
that's that's going to outer space the
best that you're ever gonna do there is
like 600 milliseconds but if you are on
a flight from Tokyo to Los Angeles your
internet traffic might actually be
bouncing off a few satellites and coming
out in Europe now if you're if you're on
that flight and you need to connect to
VPN which gateway do you pick I mean I
would probably pick the u.s. one but
that's actually the wrong one for me to
pick I should be on connect to the EU
one and there's a lot of VPN software
that can attempt to make the right
decision but we've just realised that
latency gets bad for a lot of users all
the time and it's hard for users to pick
the right thing and then lastly is that
users expect to work anywhere on if a
user has a good internet connection they
know that they have a good
connection they can get to Gmail they
can get to all these apps but their
their connectivity to our internal apps
may not be so great if they're far away
from a gateway are they're choosing our
ones it's just not working great for
them so well a user can theoretically
work from anywhere today they were able
to connect to anything today if they're
over VPN they can't really work anywhere
if it's a bad experience so we just
believe that if a user has a good
internet connection and a secure device
they should be able to work so that's
where our work anywhere project came
from and I think that's it for me
oh so one more slide so IT security at
Airbnb so where does security come into
this so I'm a secured engineer I've been
mostly talking about networking and like
user facing stuff and this slide could
have a lot of things on it on talking
about what like IT security does at
Airbnb but I think it's just really
exemplified in this this one photo of a
security key so what IT security tries
to do at Airbnb is find the best mix of
user experience and security to propel
both forward and I think that the the
security key is really like it's the
holy grail for what what that should be
so I'm proud to say that we've deployed
over 10,000 of these security keys in
Airbnb and they are the majority of our
multi factor auth are happening with
these for our internal users we don't
longer we no longer have any phone call
or SMS SMS base MFA which are obviously
insecure but they were really just a bad
user experience so we've been able to
take MFA from being a burden to
something that uses an
actually embraced and enjoy to use and
that's like that's that's what we've
been trying to do with work anywheres
propelled both user experience and
security forward from what we've had in
the past because there's a lot of ways
that you can you can have a great user
experience like if we just wanted the
best user experience we would just put
all these app started the internet but
that would obviously be horrible for
security so we've tried to avoid to do
that so with that I'm gonna hand it off
to me I'm sorry thank you he's coming
back in a minute he he'll talk about
what they actually did to solve their
problems but I did want to just
transition here for a moment all the
things as Samuel talked about with
security problems and all those
different things Google themselves we
ourselves faced about eight to ten years
ago there was a well-publicized thing of
state-sponsored hackers trying to get
into our network and so out of that we
kind of changed our model from a network
centric VPN model what we called the
beyond corporate zero trust model and so
they're really there's three tenants of
this model the first one is that you no
longer care about the network that
somebody's coming on you really really
care about the context of that request
and I'm not talking about five or six
things I'm talking about and 20
different things and you're really
thinking about that on every request to
an application and that has a lot of
ramifications about how you deploys
applications and we'll talk about that
and the key is that you should be able
to create granular level access controls
baseline if somebody's coming from a
corporate device or maybe a known or
trusted network versus a non corporate
device those people shouldn't be shut
out of being productive it just means
that what they get access to should be
limited and we'll talk about how we did
that but this is exactly the model that
Google started to follow and so when we
were putting this model together we kind
of hit on a few key tenants I don't
think there's anything that's rocket
science here but it's really important
to just walk through and kind of
understand all the components we can
talk about all the solutions for
everybody the first one it was that we
discovered is very very important to
understand users I think that's obvious
but there's other there's a there's a
secondary portion of that thing which is
that you wanted to understand user
behavior if you log in from your
mother's house every Tuesday we
shouldn't care that it's your mother's
house but we do want to know that you do
is that you have these
patterns and behaviors and something
starts to fall out of the norm we can
start to at least create speed bumps for
users along the way the second part of
this is second factor and we'll touch on
that in a minute this the other part of
that whole side of things that we found
is even if you trust a user you can
attest very strongly that the users who
they say they are the device posture
really really matters and I'll tell you
personally at Google I think we publish
this in a white paper we have the team
here you can ask them something like a
hundred and twenty five characteristics
of a request from the device itself
that's that's the two major components
but then there's a whole other context
portion of this that we really cared
about and so we run a global front-end
at Google which captures which IP
address you're running coming from we
happen to know we happen to be
constantly scanning the internet to
understand or what are good IP addresses
what our VPN IP addresses but our
state-sponsored IP addresses and we can
start to block access from those we also
understand location and time of day in
session age all the stuff needs to be
collected at the request point every
single time but then the real smarts
press came in when we started coming
down the chain the rules engine portion
we needed to be able to create human
readable and very easy to define rules
that took all those contexts in to
indicate account so you can apply them
at in fact an endpoint right and so for
us that we want to protect every piece
of data that's on the web for us we
needed to protect that's not just HTTP
it is every type of piece of data that's
out there and so that was sort of how we
came up with our beyond model and we put
tooling in place that revolves on all
this stuff and then what happened about
two or three years ago is we decided to
start productizing these piece by piece
and so what you're seeing here is that
really the story is more of a suite of
solutions than it is one singular
solution and I'll talk I'll touch on all
these things and the good news is you
don't need to adopt all or nothing there
is a gradual crawl walk run model that
we've we find ourselves at Google using
we find customers using and so we can
talk about how that would work but just
touching on each for a moment here let's
focus just turn things very quickly
the first one is cloud identity each one
of you has an identity system you don't
need to use ours but we have one that's
called the cloud identity in fact where
we manage things like users groups role
information that's all very obvious they
all sort of do that and now imagine a
world where that identity system is
locked into your calendar right
understand somebody's on vacation
somebody is in one office and not
another and a request is coming in from
somewhere strange you can start to kind
of create these sort of vectors the
other thing is you need a massive system
that does login abuse detection for us
the same system we use for the
enterprise side is what we use on the
consumer side so we are getting good at
detecting fraudulent signals because
they do 1.2 billion logins at a month
the unique logins a month and so we've
gotten very good at detecting what those
signals are those are pretty obvious
things the two other things I'll just
touch on briefly that we find that a lot
of customers don't do is session control
I don't mean infinite versus one-hour I
mean that every application has a
different use case or a different
footprint and you should be able to
create unique session length controls
for each of your types of applications
that are out there
the other one is MFA I'll say this MFA
is better than no MFA but there is a
better story than OTP if you don't
believe me just Bing OTP of fishing or
you can google it if you want
see I'm vendor agnostic but no
seriousness the OTP code have been
fished you can do a simple search for it
and see what we what we use internally
is this idea of the phyto u2f key use
any vendor it doesn't have to be us it
could be anybody we find that this makes
it I if I save unfishable you know
that's always a dangerous thing to say
so I'll say very very phishing resistant
and no credentials like Google have been
fished in the last 18 months because
we've moved to this model the second
portion of this so we talked about cloud
identity the second portion is actually
the device itself here we offer a few
solutions the one I'm going to talk
about today because I think we have a
broader story that's in other sessions
is what we call endpoint verification
and point verification is really as
simple Chrome browser based and soon
other browsers and pre-empting samuels
complaints where we understand the
security posture of a device right well
we understand the disk encryption is the
screen lock version the version of
software running on the device secured
boot all these different kinds of things
those are interesting I think what
you'll find and my friends Sanjay Sanjay
foon in today on the stage kind of
announced he kind of pre announces for
us we are working with vendors so if you
already have a mobile device management
and
a management system we are working
together with this whole ecosystem to
feed their signals into this so you can
say vendor X or partner Co is feeding
their signals in I want to use that to
make access decisions for my Google
resources and or after resources on AWS
you can certainly do that and the other
thing is you want to be able to
distinguish between corporate devices
and non corporate devices and so I think
Duggan will give a little bit of a
preview of some what we're doing there
but the idea should be that not every
device should be cut off just to get a
snack or pshew it just maybe they can't
access really secure systems and then
what you get for free when you run on us
is this idea of a Google front-end this
is a globally distributed so near zero
latency front-end that does a few things
for you one is it collects all the
context of the request the IP the
location the time of day but it also
gives you lots of things for free if you
will things like DDoS protection
enforcing TLS the latest versions of TLS
these are the kinds of things that you
need any system be able to handle and
anywhere in the world and then and the
next top of this is what we call the
access context manager if you remember
we talked about rules that you should be
able to apply the access context manager
allows you to create these levels where
you can kind of appear together these
various context things so you can say a
device that's wearing only the latest
version of OS and coming in from this IP
address for example she'll be able to
access my most secure systems anything
that's N minus 2 in terms of OS version
and maybe doesn't need second factor so
often will allow to touch second-tier
systems you should be able to create
rules like that and make them Massa
pliable if you will to all of your
systems many of you have any work in
enterprises where you're running
thousands literally thousands of IT
applications and you don't want to take
the time to go through one by one and
tag these things the access context
manager is really our paths to get there
and then you took all this context you
created all these rules and now the key
is you have to enforce it against all of
your endpoints I think what you'll find
is we have several solutions here
depending on what your use case is and
and Sammy will talk about some of these
but I'll just briefly touch on them the
first one is something we call cloud IEP
so identity we're proxies so if you're
running a web application on GCP or in
another cloud or on Prem you should be
able to protect that with through these
rules that you've defined you should
also be able do that for by the way SSH
and TCP connections as well and the
identity of proxy does exactly that and
it does what it's clever name tells you
it does it really look
the identity it looks at the context and
the next access decisions the other
thing we allow you to do is a stance or
a thing with a cloud I am system for
think of resources you have a storage
bucket let's just say that's holding a
lot of personal information you can
create context awareness around those
access to those requests as well that's
just an example you can do all of this
with our G suite products through our
cloud identity product line so you can
say I wanna be able access Gmail at this
time of day or only from a corporate
device or drive or whatever it happens
to be and then one of the areas I think
we really stand out from the other
vendors is what we call B PC service
controls this is the idea that every
public cloud is going to have their
api's on the web that's just the nature
of a cloud that's in fact what clouds
are supposed to do but it's terrifying
this idea that an employee who suddenly
goes rogue or even unintentionally takes
their device to a coffee shop and just
decides to start shutting down
production systems right for all the
other types of things we're talking
about this should be the most terrifying
to most people and today we know we now
have a product that's in GA that's
called the V PC service controls that
allows that will and the today's take
starts that has the beginnings of this
but it will start to lock take all the
same context and allow you to apply it
to public API is think of like storage
buckets and VM productions and things
like that
you'll be able to apply these same
controls there and more will be coming
as you go along so I think it's one
thing to talk about it more interesting
attend demo it so I'll have Duggan come
up in and go through some demos
thank you meet hello everyone my name is
Karan Arora and I'm a product manager in
Google cloud as a me just touched on
context-aware access is the key pillar
for beyond corp security model and you
all can imagine a lot of use cases when
you think of context so imagine that you
want to control access to your resources
based on where the user is coming from
or what what you know about their device
how secure that is there are so many use
cases that we can talk about but or next
few minutes I'm going to go through two
specific use cases one on the GCP side
and one on G suite side to highlight how
you can enable context where access in
your organization after that Sam is
going to come in again and he's going to
talk about how they are deploying Google
tools to address their use cases so
let's look at the use case one right so
this is something that we heard over and
over from our customers that I want to
allow access to all my applications to
users from wherever they are but there
is a HR application that I may have
where I want to restrict access to
contractors only if they are coming from
a corporate location so let's see how
that works in our scenario so since this
is an HR application on GCP an end-user
can access this application from
wherever they are now the admin wants to
enforce the use case that we just
described and essentially I want to
restrict the access based on the
location of contractors network so I go
in to access context manager create a
rule called access level and I define
the contractor IP address first the next
thing I want to do is since these
applications behind the load balancer I
want to enable IEP for this and this
allows me to configure who can get
access to this application and under
what conditions so in this case I am
give me access to Bob who's my
contractor but only if he is coming from
his corporate network so once I set this
rule I can go back and check and make
sure that bob has acts
to this application and now we'll look
at it from Bob scenario when he is
trying to access this HR application so
in the first scenario bob is in office
and he's logged into his device and he's
able to access this application because
he's on the corporate network now let's
say Bob goes to a coffee shop to get a
cup of coffee and he tries to access
that application again and in that case
because he's not from the corporate
network he's still logged in but he is
denied access so as you can see it's
fairly easy for you to set up these kind
of contextual rules that allow you to
restrict access to the applications that
may reside on GCP on Prem or any other
club now let's touch on the case for G
Street site this is again a fairly
common scenario that we see among our
customers where I am a customer with lot
of sensitive data in my driving Doc's so
think of dark shields and anything else
I want to make sure that users who are
coming to access this Drive and Doc's
are coming in only if they have a secure
device and I'll walk you through exactly
how you can define your version of
security device over the next few steps
the first thing you need to do or your
end users need to have is something
called endpoint verification it's a
chrome plug-in that either they can
install themselves or you as an admin
can push it to their devices once the
end users have endpoint verification
installed as an admin you go to your
familiar admin console in your security
settings you'll see a tab now called
context where access once you click on
it you'll be able to set different
access levels to define the conditions
and then you can apply them to different
resources so in this case as you can see
the corporate office IP that we defined
shows up here but we're going to fine a
new rule called secure device once you
create it you are able to choose
different attributes that you can use to
define what the secure device means for
your organization
in this case I picked three specific
attributes one I want to make sure that
any device accessing my driving docks
has a password on number two I want to
make sure that the device is encrypted
and number three I want to make sure
that the device is fairly up-to-date and
in this case I define that the Mac OS
version should be 1000 which is fairly
high version that I want to define once
you create this access level it's going
to show up in the list of all access
level that you have defined and you can
choose other attributes like is the
device corporate owned or not is a doc
Chrome OS device which I trust and has
verified access so on and so on and so
forth
so once you have defined the access
level the next step is to actually go
and assign those access level to
resources you want to protect and you
can do it on the entire domain that you
have or you can pick a subset of users
which we call organization unit and
apply the same rules to only a subset of
users so in this case I apply this rules
to drive and dogs for contractors and I
picked that any contractor who's
accessing drive and dogs should be
coming with a secure device
so once I've defined this any contractor
who does not meet the minimum criteria
that I have said is not going to be able
to access the drive and docks that
belong to my organization so let's see
again we go back to the our contractor
Bob who's trying to access this
application
he does have endpoint verification
installed and this is something that
sends the device information back to us
where we can check for contextual
information the next thing we check is
the OS version of the device that Bob
has he has a version of 10 dot 13.6 so
this is higher than 10.0.0.0 in dogs
when he tries to access his documents
now imagine a security vulnerability has
come out and Apple has released a new
patch and you want all your users to be
coming from this latest patch when
they're accessing these sensitive
documentation all you have to do in this
case is to go back to your access level
that you defined update the OS version
that you define 10.0.0.0 and out 14.2
and all this happens behind the scenes
where it gets triggered down as a policy
to all the users and all the
applications that was applied to and in
this case when Bob tries to access the
same application again he will be denied
access because it's OS version 10.13 dot
6 is lower than 10.14 door to that you
as an admin requires so as you can see
it's fairly simple to apply these rules
across your organization on GCP t suite
you pick your attributes and signals
that you want to use that in context and
then apply these rules we also have a
live demo running on your right side so
feel free to go there and we'd love to
hear more about your use cases and how
contexts where access can solve it for
you guys and with that I'll invite Sam
back and is going to talk more about IP
and context were access and how they
have deployed this to solve the Reece
case
thank you so when IP was first announced
a couple of years ago I was pretty
excited by it because we already used G
suite and we already used cloud identity
for our users
so having users that like would already
integrate what this was pretty cool and
pretty useful but the question was could
it help us solve our problems with our
user experience like making the user
experience better we had a pretty good
grasp on user authentication but just
authenticating was more than we needed
what we really cared about was device
hit as well especially since we've
invested so much in our endpoints over
the last three years so we tried other
authenticated proxies and I personally
use something in the in the past usually
labeled as client list VPN but they just
kind of ended up causing more problems
and then they purported to solve so we
needed something different and that
would enhance our security and our user
experience with IEP working as part of a
load balancer it seemed to kind of fit
how modern apps work so setting up the
context there were three things that we
were trying to achieve here one was
consistent access so regardless of where
somebody it was they should be able to
access the applications that they need
to do their job
there one easy method so we're in the
past we've had 802 1x VPN and other
methods to get to an application it ends
up confusing users where sometimes they
need VPN for something sometimes they
need 802 1x and VPN for something and it
just is is it presents a large confusion
for our users so we wanted like
consistent access
per application we knew that we were
still
VPN for some things but for each
application the access should be
consistent we wanted to enhance
application performance especially for
users that are far away from these apps
so we have we have thousands of users
that are thousands of miles away from
the applications that they're using and
well it would be wonderful if every
application that we use supported
multi-region deployments that's just not
the reality especially when we're when
we're buying third-party apps they might
be able to work in like an H a kind of
configuration but they're going to want
to be deployed all next to each other so
we're just going to have to pick a
region for an app to run in and deal
with that so we want to enhance
application performance have the best
the best networking that we could and
lastly because security is important but
maybe shouldn't be the first thing on
your mind for everything out there is
that we want to enforce the endpoint
endpoint security state that we've
implemented over the past few years so
we're really happy with the way that our
that our Mac Windows and Chrome OS
endpoints are managed but if we're not
actually enforcing that those devices
are the ones connecting to our
applications I don't know if there's
truly a point to us having done that so
the first thing that you're gonna run
into if you want to use contacts where
access is the endpoint verification
extension and the data that this
extension gives you is incredibly
powerful and incredibly valuable so we
actually deploy this extension almost
two years ago and it's been collecting
data for us ever since so one of the
problems that companies run into over
their growth is that their inventory
their physical inventory isn't as
they think it is so when you hand a
laptop to somebody the first thing
you're doing when you're growing is
you're probably gonna have a spreadsheet
and you're gonna like say who you
assigned it to and then you'll grow into
some on like physical inventory
management system but that data in there
is only as good as the data that you put
in there and most that's in a manual and
that doesn't scale to having thousands
and thousands of endpoints so before we
before we went and used IEP for anything
we roll this extension out and it will
tell you who's actually using your
devices so we force install this
extension on all of our managed devices
and found that you know definitely less
than a hundred percent of our devices
were assigned to the people who are
actually using them so here's a list of
my devices that I'm using and some of
them are company-owned some of their
user owned and here's an example of my
macbook pro and it shows this basic
security state
it shows company owned and we can use
that data to inform our physical
inventory we can also use that to inform
products or access so here's the thing
we don't use GCP to run our applications
like I said before airbnb.com runs all
in AWS and we have some applications
that run on Prem as well
but IEP with context where we're still
very appealing to us because our users
exists in Google our internal users so
how could we achieve this when when IEP
runs and load balancing the load
balancer can't target apps which run
outside of GCP so this is what the
diagram of this ended up looking like
so we have our users who talk to talk to
the load balancer which goes to and
talks to I pee and behind the load
balancer we have just nginx and we've
yeah so we've set up nginx and that
routes the traffic all the way back to
the third-party apps running in ec2 so
thankfully when we built when we rebuilt
our network over the last few years we
kind of anticipated that we'd be
connecting to more than just AWS in the
future now we weren't really thinking
about connecting to other clouds but we
knew that we'd probably have some like
IPSec VPN is going to vendors or
something like that so getting a partner
interconnect set up to land right next
to the AWS Direct Connect that we're
using was probably one of the easiest
parts of this project and the only thing
that we've had to actually deploy in GCP
is this nginx instance or nginx
instances really but you could very well
use a different kind of proxy you can
use envoy if you wanted to that's the
cool new thing you could even deploy
that in kubernetes but we we have a lot
of familiarity with nginx so we're using
that I mean it goes over the partner
interconnect and ends up back at the
application so that's that's pretty easy
like it's it's fairly straightforward on
nginx just run as far as the traffic
users can get to the apps we can use
endpoint verification and that informs
the beyond Corp which acts as context
manager references and then we also have
OS query and other endpoint
instrumentation along with our physical
inventory talking to stream alert and
then talking to lambdas that we've
written that talk back to DCP that talk
back to beyond Corp and inform other
access
so that was for third-party apps but we
have a lot of applications that we've
written internally and they're primarily
behind a tool called internal off on
which is an identity aware proxy long
before 0 trust and Beyond Corp on all
these words everybody built its own
authenticated proxy for this because we
were building all these internal
applications but we didn't want to
rebuild authentication every single time
so this is in front of tools that are
Hadoop front ends and other critical
business applications like the lunch
menu so this is what internal auth has
looked like for a very long time users
come in through VP an array of 2 and X
they come through the Direct Connect and
then they talk to an engine X proxy
which has some middleware on it which
authenticates to open LDAP and also does
MFA so when it authenticates open LDAP
it gets that users information which
includes their LDAP UID and the groups
that they're a member of and adds those
two headers which get passed on to other
applications which are running in ec2
which know what to do with those headers
so we wanted to rebuild this and get the
authentication to not be all that based
like we're moving towards this like new
buzzword of like password list future
but this was still using traditional all
that boss we were thinking like could we
add this to sam'l or add sam'l off to
this but that was kind of complicated so
as we deployed IEP in front of
third-party apps we kept running in to
the HTTP request headers which come
through in every single request
and in them you'll see this goog IP
jadibooti assertion which is this big
long header there must be a lot of data
in there and what it is is it's a signed
header which is telling you more about
what's going on so if we verify that and
to code that we can see that this is the
information contained within the data
bTW we get the user's email we get their
access levels which is really nice those
can be reused in the future so if you
want to have your end applications you
know maybe make access decisions to
different types of data and instead of
just access to the application if you
want to have like different regions be
able to access different things you can
reuse this data but what we were really
looking at here was the email so this
has my email in it but that's not really
what we needed what we needed was the
LDAP UID in the groups we wanted to
deploy this without making any changes
to the applications so this is what we
ended up doing this is what we've been
working on like over the last few weeks
actually so this is a little bit
different from last item it's a little
bit simplified I'm not including the
like the full access context manager
path but we can see here that IP ads on
this HTTP header to the requests and now
since the users already logged in
through IEP our middleware has been much
simplified so instead of the middleware
authenticating the user it's just going
to open LDAP to take that email and
resolve it to an LDAP UID and get the
same user and group information that we
always had to pass it along to those
applications so we still have a very
similar deployment as we've had but
users get a much simplified experience
because they're already logged in
they're not having to login a second
time
RMF phase simplified and we're able to
you know bypass VPN and you know to 1x
for these applications so to kind of
wrap up my part on I have to say that
not everything is perfect with IEP and
contacts aware right now so this is a
pleading face so this is everything that
I plead to meet about that I've been
promised is going to be fixed in the
future so non G's feedback and support
the way we're doing with nginx is kind
of a hack
I mean nginx is a known beast but I
don't really want to run those anymore
so in the future GCP load balancers are
going to support network endpoint groups
so they support network Wratten point
groups I think it's it was in beta as of
recently it might be GA now but what we
really need is network endpoint groups
to be hybrid so we can target things
outside of GCP and that would allow us C
or nginx it would make deploying this
way easier this is a big sticking point
chrome is the only supported browser for
Chrome is only supported desktop bars
for endpoint verification so if you have
users using Safari or Firefox or edge
and you want to verify any of their
endpoint state it's just not gonna work
they're not gonna have access today iOS
Android support not yet generally
available but I I've been told it will
be beta soon for third-party apps
because the session time of IEP sessions
is only one hour if you're using Ajax II
apps the the callbacks will start to
fail after an hour if you write your own
apps you can do session refreshing
session refreshing yourself but if
you're using third-party apps you're
probably going to need to inject inject
an iframe into those applications nginx
is really good at that
that's what we're doing
um but that's a headache that you'll
probably run into and then applications
that might have a like mix of sick
clients and web clients that might hit
the same end points are gonna be really
hard to deal with but not everything is
terrible I want to leave you with some
things that I do like so
oh they're all appearing at once but if
if a web application is can live behind
a web live behind Oh No if a if a what
there's there's a missing
smiley face there if web can live behind
load balancer it's probably gonna be
really easy to use IP with it and the
Google front end really helps us with
having performant access to these apps
the session initiation is really fast
and the premium network is definitely
better than the general internet so when
we have users coming from very far it
helps us a lot
and then the the information that we get
in the JW teas is very useful and I'm
very excited about the future state of
context layer for IEP to suite and sam'l
so we have consistent access to
everything thank you
[Music]